Hey youtubers it's Charlie and a bunch of
Avengers Age of Ultron story details supposedly
leaked in addition to Mark Ruffalo teasing
a new Hulk Standalone movie.
So this is going to be a breakdown of all
of that.
The Avengers stuff is only supposed to come
from the first twenty minutes of the movie
so I don't consider it crazy with spoilers.
Hello to all you new people, I'm going to
be doing Marvel videos every week all summer.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Guardians of the Galaxy is coming up, but
I try to rotate movies whenever there's something
really interesting to talk about with you
guys.
So Avengers 2, a bunch of bloggers and news
outlets were invited to the set of the movie
in England and got to see the inside of the
new Avengers Tower including the rooms they'll
be sleeping in.
Like Thor's bedroom.
It's the same tower we saw in the first Avengers
movie when it had the Stark Logo on the outside.
They also got to see the quintjet.
Yes there is a quintjet in the movie and they
got to see the first 20 minutes of the movie.
So the details about the story seem legit,
but they're only from the first part of the
movie careful for spoilers in case you don't
want to know anything.
The movie is supposed to start directly after
that Baron Von Strucker scene in Winter Soldier.
The Avengers are in the process of cleaning
up the remnants of HYDRA just like Nick Fury
said he was doing.
They are conducting a hit on that lab Baron
Von Strucker is in.
It's a big opening action set piece.
Remember how Thor The Dark World opened the
movie with that big battle on Vanaheim.
This is the same type of thing.
Just start the movie with a lot of explosions.
Baron Von Strucker is a lot like Hannibal
Chau from Pacific Rim, remember Ron Perlman's
character, he'd run in and steal bits of the
Kaiju's to use for experiments and shady stuff.
Von Strucker has the corpse of one of the
Chitauri Leviathans from the battle of New
York along with a bunch of chitauri weaponry
and Loki's Staff.
Which supposedly is powered by the mind gem.
The Avengers are there to clean up the mess.
And that's when they run into Scarlet Witch
and Quicksilver.
Who battle the Avengers.
So this opening scene is also a good intro
to their characters and showing off their
shiny new powers that we haven't seen in the
Marvel Universe yet.
Scarlet Witch confounds Hulk making see a
bunch of crazy stuff, causing him smash the
shit out of everything, eventually the Avengers
win and take Loki's staff and everything else
back to the Avengers Tower.
Then the film breaks into a post win party.
Like their team just won the world cup and
it's time to throw down.
How do the Avengers party when they're hanging
out.
Supposedly by taking turns trying to pick
up Thor's Hammer.
Tony Stark tries while he's wearing his new
Armor.
He's got a new version of the Armor in this
movie of course.
When he lays into it the arm on his suit just
rips out of it's socket.
But Captain America is able to make it budge,
just a little.
In case you've never read the comics, Captain
America is able to wield Thor's Hammer.
But they haven't done this in the movies yet,
so in Avengers 2 we might get to see Captain
America use Thor's Hammer.
Also in the comics, because Captain America
has the most noble heart, he's the one the
illuminati allow to wear the infinity gauntlet
when it contains all six gems.
He's like the one person who wouldn't go mad
with power.
So of course he'd pass Odin's test and be
able to pick up Thor's Hammer.
Later we find out that Black Widow and Bruce
Banner have a thing going on the side but
because Banner is afraid of turning into the
Hulk while they're having sex, they don't
have a physical relationship.
If you were a Joss Whedon Buffy fan, then
it's going to remind you of Buffy and Angel.
And speaking of 'ships.
If you didn't like Natalie Portman in Thor
The Dark World, she and Thor are supposedly
not together anymore.
So she's not really going to be in the movie
other than a minor cameo.
So what did we learn about the story?
Mostly that the Avengers are going to be running
toxic waste disposal missions between Winter
Soldier and Avengers 2.
So when Guardians of The Galaxy is happening,
they'll just be in the middle of all that.
All these films happen chronologically.
So Winter Soldier is happening before Guardians
and Ant Man will happen after the events of
Avengers 2.
But based on this information, what are you
most excited to see in the movie.
We don't have a ton of Ultron details yet,
other than his origins via Militarized Stark
Tech.
The thing I'm really excited to see is Scarlet
Witch mess with the Hulk's mind so he goes
crazy on everyone and Captain America using
Thor's Hammer.
It's possible that scene of Hulk fighting
Iron Man in his Hulkbuster Armor was from
that Scarlet Witch scene.
The Hulkbuster stuff was all shot in South
America, so that sounds like where Baron Von
Strucker's Lab is going to be.
I don't know how I feel about Avengers hooking
up with each other.
Especially when the squad is so small.
Maybe when there are like twenty Avengers
I could see it happening.
But this is a Joss Whedon project.
And if you've ever watched something of his
then you know.
The minute a bunch of crazy people get together,
two of them will start having sex with each
other.
In this case the crazy people just happen
to be earth's last defenders.
Doesn't that just remind you of High School.
More from Mark Ruffalo on The Hulk though,
he's been doing a lot of interviews lately.
He's been teasing a stand alone Hulk Film.
Marvel has probably been developing it quietly
ever since they cast him, but they have a
billion other films they want to do first.
Avengers 2 is supposed to put the Hulk front
and center, much more so than the last film.
So his character will be a core part of the
story.
That doesn't mean it will be all Hulk, but
this will be the closest thing to a Hulk movie
we'll get until at least Phase 3 or Phase
4.
So because Guardians of The Galaxy is almost
here in less than a month, I'm going to do
a few bonus videos for it starting next week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I also just posted details on the new Arrow
Season 3 comic book characters.
You can click here to learn about them and
click here to learn about Thanos in Guardians
of the Galaxy.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!